le collège les deux canons à saint denis
s'est mis au diapason de la fête de la
musique en participant à une
manifestation mise en place par le
conseil départemental
permettant les échanges entre les
collégiens et un artiste du quartier
alors le travail s'est fait de façon
quand même assez rapide le groupe k
bernard mas il avait été contacté je
crois par monsieur dans le sur ferreira
le prof de musique dont je vous parlais
donc ils sont venus répéter et là tout
au long de la journée heure par heure ce
sont des 1 5 3 4 classes qui à chaque
heure vont venir voir le spectacle le
groupe kabar marmaille composé de cinq
artistes a proposé aux collégiens des
deux canons un medley de 40 minutes de
chansons traditionnelles réunionnaise
l'idée c'est aussi de venir avec notre
bonne humeur et ses mensonges longtemps
comme à tirano et nos instruments alors
parce qu'il ya aussi des stationnements
qui peuvent être un peu surprenant on
voit pas souvent donc c'est une occasion
aussi de les montrer de les faire jouer
vraiment peu de données donner envie que
ces musiques là soient présents que ce
soit pas simplement une histoire de
passer pour les anciens parce que ces
jeunes là et les enfants vont avoir des
enfants un jour et je pense que c'est
important que
on puisse transmettre mon mari pêcheur
picazo pas et voilà tout ça c'est le
patrimoine et il faut que ça continue
les élèves du collège se sont également
mises en scène en proposant un concert
de maloya mettant en jeu de nombreux
instruments traditionnels des jeunes
pour qui il est important de perpétuer
la musique locale
là ça fait trois ans que l'on se bat
sans faire de mal
pour ceux qui comme moi mais tous
coupables nous
convient pas le mal
à
cette opération se fonde sur les
orientations stratégiques du conseil
départemental la collectivité jure sur
la carte de la proximité et de l'échangé
en permettant au collège de s'ouvrir sur
son quartier et bien souvent dans notre
l'âge et les jeunes qui n'ont pas
forcément l'accessibilité à l'offre
culturelle et d'eau en revenant aux
sources
le dépassement a véritablement choisi
amener la culture auprès de nos
collégiens et non plus supporter atdjian
collégiens il y à une programmation
venez nous voir donc il s'agit
véritablement de jouer la
décentralisation au toit de la musique à
l'occasion de cette fête de la musique